last year in june apple showed off their
brand new groundbreaking universal
control feature which absolutely blew
the minds of everyone watching the
keynote including myself and what it
allowed you to do was to magically
control your ipad from your macbook or
mac alone and just switch over to the
ipad and then switch over to the mac and
then to another mac all with one
keyboard and trackpad built into a
macbook and it was just mind-blowing
because it works using airplay and
bluetooth automatically without having
to do anything else and if that wasn't
magical enough it even enabled you to
drag and drop files to and from your mac
and ipad devices just like that so this
is basically the dream multitasking
setup for people who have both a mac and
an ipad especially with the fact that
you can transfer files easily without
having to go into airdrop or anything
like that and when apple originally
announced it they said it was going to
be coming later in the fall but
unfortunately that never happened but
finally after almost eight months apple
has just released the new universal
control feature within the latest
developer beta versions of mac os and
ipad os so that is exactly what i have
downloaded and installed on both of
these apple devices and in this video
i'm going to show you how it works and
i'm gonna teach you everything you need
to know to get it set up and use it so
let's get right into it first up if
you're watching this video at a later
date there's a good chance that this
feature has already officially launched
across apple's devices so the first step
is to make sure you've updated the
software on both your mac and your ipad
and now the second step is to make sure
you're signed into the same icloud
account on both devices or else it's not
going to work so don't forget the stat
and now getting into the actual setup it
should work by itself automatically by
default but if it doesn't you can go
over on your mac and go into the system
preferences or the settings then go down
to the display options then click on
advanced and here you should see all of
the new options the first one is to
allow your cursor and keyboard to move
between a nearby mac or ipad then you
have the next one which is it allows you
to push through the edge of the display
to connect to a nearby mac or ipad and
then finally you have the option to
automatically reconnect if you always
have it set up like this at home and you
always want it to work automatically
without having to do anything and now
moving over to the ipad side you're
going to want to go into the system
preferences then go down to general
then go to airplay and hand off and here
you should see the handoff enabled and
the new cursor and keyboard control
beta option that should be enabled by
default as well so make sure that is on
now if you've gone through this step and
you're having some issues and it's not
automatically working another thing you
can do is go down into the display
settings on the mac click add display
and you should see your ipad under the
section that says link keyboard and
mouse so if you see it just go ahead and
click it
and there you go you should see the
connection you have your macbook pro on
the left and the ipad on the right now
this is really cool because apple is
able to instantly see where your ipad is
so if you move this over to the other
side it'll automatically detect it so
it's really awesome and i do like the
extra little detail that they have your
wallpaper shown there as well so that's
really cool so let's go ahead close that
down and let's test it out all right
here we go the moment of truth
oh look at that it's so seamless and
it's perfect look it's perfectly
matching the speed
wow that's incredible there you go
we have it on
the ipad and we could simply just go
into
into google just like that and now i
want to try out the oh
the gestures work
it's perfectly smooth and now i'm back
wow this is incredible i cannot believe
how good this works for a beta i don't
think there is any latency at all and
look i can even go in i'm controlling
the brightness everything
from
the macbook trackpad i wonder what will
happen if i switch over and use the
actual ipad's magic keyboard trackpad
look it it instantly took over and look
as you can see i don't know if you can
see but it swapped
the trackpad the cursor back to the mac
as soon as i
switch to the ipad so now let's see what
will happen if i go back in
seamless
okay look i'm gonna use this bam it
resets let's see what happens if i turn
off
the display
there you go it's back it's perfectly
seamless and now let's go ahead and test
out the
keyboard
look at that no latency let's check out
a maxtec video
just like that i'm controlling
everything and it's so precise too look
at that comments
there's no latency guys
wow it's so fast and if i switch back to
this one oh it's instant and now the
next thing i want to test out is if i
can move a safari tab over to the ipad i
wonder if that's possible let's see
and nope looks like that does not work
you cannot move a tab over what if i
move a full window over okay the full
window does not move over unfortunately
that does not
work all right now let's say you want to
use your ipad as the main device to
control the macbook so got the trackpad
right here and let's move over
look at that you've got the macbook
cursor everything works
keyboard
no issues
i can't believe it this is magical
this is like the craziest unexpected
feature that apple has ever made and
it's crazy because this is also going to
work with desktop mac so you can use
your ipad to control a desktop mac or
vice versa or like a macbook to control
the desktop mac this is just
absolutely insane alright now what about
doing something like copying and pasting
so let's type in max tech youtube copy
that go over here
and paste it oh we faced it wow guys
that is going to be so useful because
imagine you're doing like spreadsheets
or something else like that or you got a
word document over here you're working
on something else here you want to copy
and paste it just works now by far the
coolest feature that apple showed off
was drag and drop support so let's see
if it works
look at that i just dragged it over
and i could access it just like that
there wasn't even a loading bar it
literally just moved over let's try a
video okay i'm gonna grab this video
from like one of our
tests actually i'm gonna use the macbook
keyboard just move it over
no
look at that it's transferring and there
you go
it's looking up it's playing
i can't believe it all right let's try
multiple all right this could be the
moment of truth right here
no way it just added them in multiple
select drag and drop works perfectly
fine now what if we try the reverse
let's go from the macbook over to the
ipad
no
it worked there it is let's go ahead and
go over to the files app let's move over
some basic files let's see uh zip file
boom dmg file
i can't believe it transfer that quickly
guys splash fox blender project
that did not work looks like the file is
unsupported but everything else like
these zip files working perfectly i
literally just can't believe it works so
seamlessly and so smoothly it just blows
my mind and just the drag and drop
feature alone not having to go into
airdrop and transfer it over
i just can't believe it works so well
and it's so useful
i could see myself using this and apple
you seriously killed it with this
feature so if you guys agree with me go
ahead leave your comments below let me
know what you think and if you enjoyed
the video go ahead and click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one and definitely check one out
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you